you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy network
this is a bi bicycle
podcast uh where each week i
lunatic online shoe kicker offer
shower have taken her dave anthony
reads a story from american history to
my
best best best best best guy the best
thing that ever happened to me before
him i was in a closet
shouting alone gareth reynolds who
not know story about
i was like we held the same microphone
at the same time and body swap
i mean that was like have you ever seen
freaky friday i've read a lot about it
have you read the novels because i've
read the books yeah there's there's
19 freaky weekies i've read freaky
weekies
freaky seeky
but yeah no i've read all those i've
read the series of the freakies
yeah i mean i'm gonna start a podcast a
freaky friday podcast just about the
whole freaky friday you know when you
should put it out
thursdays [ __ ]
we work together so well badly oh sorry
we're gonna oh we're good this is the
action not
right yes okay take it to the band
but the music just ended you sit
yesterday all right i started
quote his jam pack champ i'm the [ __ ]
hippo guy dave okay
yeah dog listen uh well we're brought to
you in part by zip recruiter oh you're
getting ready um they recruit zips
yep look if you're uh uh you're a
business owner
and you have a like a company like
gerkora a heavy cat lifting company
you probably don't really specialize in
it all you probably face a lot of
challenges when it comes to finding the
right person
for your role right right yes not enough
applicants for the right you know skill
level i want the right person for the
right job get too many resumes
yeah you need to hire right away i hired
somebody to deal with the resumes
that's right like all these resumes come
in and there's no one that can really
lift a cat that's again that's why
hiring can feel like
trying to find a needle in a haystack
yeah yeah yeah you can post your
job to some job board but then all you
can do is hope the right person is going
to come along
which is why you should try
ziprecruiter.com for free at
ziprecruiter.com
uh you know you post on zip recruiter it
gets sent out to
over 100 job sites uh with just one
click and then
zipper critter's got this matching
technology right and it finds the
people with the right skills and
experience yes
for your job right for my job job
better uh so he just a big cat
people experience with like a large
sealish
animal like uh
it's just not that big uh in fact zip
code is so effective that four out of
five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first
day first day something
so while other companies overwhelm you
with way too many options zip recruiter
finds what you're looking for
the needle and the haystack and right
now you can try zippercutter for free at
this web address ziprecruiter.com once
again
remember to go to this unique place
ziprecruiter.com dollop d-o-l-l-o-p
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
yeah
you like that yes yes very into it me my
candy man
not gonna answer are you my candy man
just keep reading
we're also brought to you in part uh by
the zebra
so wait what what's happening what this
is this even
okay i hope this is right um
do i check no no i guess it is
this is bad gareth
we're brought to you in part by the
zebra look some facts are fun sure
some facts are just fun sure like uh the
first oranges weren't orange they were
green
wow armadillo shells
are actually bulletproof i wish someone
had tried to figure that out yeah how
did they
what texas right yeah um turkeys can
blush
okay sure the current american flag was
designed by a high school student
that doesn't surprise me here's the
here's a not great fun fact not fun at
all
uh americans overspend on insurance by
21 billion every year
yes that's where the zebra can help you
the zebra compares car and home
insurance quotes from every major
provider in under five minutes
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision
for you thank you all for free it's the
fastest way to find the right coverage
at the right place all from a provider
you can trust
in fact zebras save shoppers an average
of 922
on home and car insurance combined and
that's a very fun fact
uh you know the zebra is very easy you
just go on there
the website put in your information
bam you get a bunch of offers okay it's
beautiful it looks
sexy okay it's clean interesting
it's like me in a hot tub get all the
facts in one place start comparing
quotes
for free today by visiting the zebra.com
that's the zebra.com slash
dollop do it
uh david we should point out that we are
back
in road shape we both have gotten our
bodies
nice and flabby and doughy for the tour
we will be uh in vegas
at wise guys las vegas september 14th
september 16th will be at guys in salt
lake city we're
calling it the wise week um and then
also
we're at the high plains comedy festival
at the paramount theater in denver on
saturday september 18th
uh and then we also have uh phoenix is
coming up we're waiting for a link
and then in november we'll be going to
san francisco sacramento
and san diego you go to
dolloppodcast.com for all the
information on that and we're also going
to australia
assuming things make a u-turn um
we'll be in perth adelaide canberra
sydney brisbane
sydney again what the hell melbourne
auckland and
wellington so go to dollarpodcast.com
for
all that ticket information and that and
then i
personally without dave thank god we'll
be this weekend
at comedy on state in madison wisconsin
august 5th i'll be at cb live in phoenix
arizona august 6th and 7th
uh and eighth i'll be at the uh rally
improv
in north carolina august 19th dallas
texas
at hyenas august 20th the state theater
in austin texas
august 21st the rec room houston texas
26 spokane comedy club spokane
washington oopsie
and the 27th i'll be at the tacoma
comedy club in tacoma washington go to
gareth.com for all the ticket
information
good work there dave someone needed to
make it look like there was a cup in my
mouth
so we both did great i'm proud of myself
and i think aaron is proud of me
uh okay all right everybody had fun
i didn't enjoy did you mention denver in
there yes high plains comedy festival
will be in denver
join us okay it's the comeback
may 16th 1928
year of our lord jesus christ yes
christo yes alfred emmanuel
martin was born in berkeley california
his birth was delayed because the doctor
would break it was delayed
can he wait 45 minutes to come out sure
absolutely
when this lights up and vibrates we have
an area for him so just have him bring
it up to the hose stand push it back in
my uncle uh i'm the hospital's kicker
uh my uncle was pushed back in because
the doctor wasn't there yet
oh my god he's always been a little slow
oh my god um i mean can you
rejecting nature on that level no no no
no you don't get to play earth bouncer
the nurse did
the door of the vagina sorry we're at
capacity can you
come back maybe around and come back
tomorrow i don't think they called the
door of the vagina
the vaginal door
hello hello there's walls where's your
yes
so the birth was delayed because the
doctor would not come to the house
unless it was wired for electricity
okay so they quit again arranged for the
house
to be wired for electricity that's the
route you go yeah wow
yeah okay fine we'll remodel it's really
like there's an
arm you know what i'm saying i love the
doctors
i'm going to need a smoking room some
strobe lights
i was told there'd be billions i'm
afraid i can't
do the birth until there's a billiard
table please so alfred was born is there
no art in here i mean it's just a little
drab
that's all there is that's it i really
asked for a number of things well this
is just a birth so we're just going to
have the baby come out fresh milk in the
fridge and things of that nature maybe
some pastries or
no we don't have pastries now we have
kitchen's yellow huh
i'd love to see it white before we did
this i i i
just at least the cabinet can the baby's
coming like we can't can i see the
cabinets white
do you have any swatches i no why no
okay
okay i mean it's fine it's just um
there's a no there's no party sub or
anything
no so i should have come having had
yeah you're a doctor that i'm aware
you've done some good stuff i like that
there's electricity now it's just
you know i'm going to get very hungry
and i just didn't know whether to
okay that's fine and you're we're no way
on the cabinets we haven't even no we
can't there we go
have you ever done have you ever done a
kitchen remodel it takes forever
i'm a doctor right now that's my
department you don't need to tell me
that
okay what i'm asking about is you have
you even gotten some estimates
on the cabinets in the kitchen no the
baby it's gonna be yeah
it's gonna be yellow you're sticking to
okay all right even if we had a
contractor there wouldn't be
time to get it start breaking ground on
it
and i'll go do the baby thing okay
okay yeah let's update each other in 15
minutes
okay until i see some swatches though i
don't think it's right to bring a child
into this house
a yellow kitchen it's rather
embarrassing
i mean the fridge is white
no boy well i should get moving
seems like my job did it so for me
that's the thing about my job
more of a monitor i don't really force
much
all right good thank you all right
that'll be a thousand dollars
came all the way over here it's actually
cheap
um so uh babe was born upstairs and then
they circumcised him on the kitchen
table
ah yum perfect yes we'll be eating here
tomorrow
isn't it weird we'll never be able to
eat here without thinking of the tip of
his [ __ ] isn't that funny
um so his grandmother cooed bellow at
him
a time for beautiful um and from that
day forward they called him
billy billy martin okay
okay you see aaron yeah yeah
yeah his mother jenny was
known to fly into a rage if anyone says
said she was shorter than five feet tall
she would lose her mind if anyone said
she was under five feet yes okay she was
actually 411.
okay so she's um fighting reality is
really where her b-flat
that's right right she's a sex worker
okay
uh married okay her husband al would go
out and drag her off the streets she's
working the streets you drag off the
streets and
and make her come home okay that seems
like a really fine marriage
yeah yeah a pretty volatile relationship
when billy was just a baby she held a
knife
to baby billy's neck and said if al
didn't leave
she'd kill billy so al left
because that's a red flag yeah oh no
that's not okay
you can't do that every mother has their
different techniques i'm putting him
back
in he's going back in that's it
he's out of here so um
billy liked baseball and pro baseball
players would train at a park near their
house
in the off season okay it's near billy's
house yeah okay
so he started hanging out there okay and
uh
and so they started you know helping the
kid out showing him things
sure and he learned if he wasn't good
enough to always
do more and to hustle okay
he's also a huge fighter he loves yeah
we fight
i feel like he's come up in other
baseball episodes yeah i'm sure he has
he's definitely been he was definitely
in
i forgot to put that in here but he was
in the um was he in 10 cent beer night
he was in 10 cent beer knight and he's
also in um
uh glenn um oh right right
yeah right uh gay basically right right
right five
yep but i i didn't put that in i forgot
i forgot to put that in but
this could have been a five-parter okay
sure like this is
this when i usually my scripts are five
to seven pages sure
this was 34. okay that's fine that's
good that's great
we sleep here tonight uh so i cut it way
down but anyway
um okay so he learned he learns to
hustle he didn't start playing baseball
he's also a big fighter he he
he's on the streets of berkeley he's
fighting all the time
and then he's the best fighter he he
he's in a boxing club but he's the best
street fighter so
other kids always want to fight him okay
he's that guy that he's the guy you want
to take out
which is not a great position to be in
if you're the guy
no that's like what killed houdini yeah
it was just like someone was just like
hey it's the guy you could punch
like it's not like you know what i mean
like i need a little time i need a green
room
it's a whole thing yeah i got a whole
thing i do beforehand yeah
but he like he had a big nose so people
would always make fun of his nose
that's it sure the fists are flying
immediately you know
um so jenny's advice to him was the main
advice for life was
quote don't take [ __ ] from nobody wow
jesus it's not i mean okay
it's just that's quite like if you think
you get to put a bumper sticker on your
child early
do you want to go with that yeah don't
take [ __ ] from nobody you know maybe
just like
i mean i'm not saying we slap the
coexist one on because that seems also
fairly vacuous
that's also not great but uh [ __ ]
nobody okay uh and uh
he usually threw the first punch he was
a first punch guy okay
he's very good baseball player right in
high school very good uh he did get
suspended for a whole season in high
school because he
uh fought during a game he got into a
whole season suspension in high school
is
i can only imagine how bad the fight was
but i also don't think
you you there was fighting in the majors
and the minors but
you didn't fight in high school you know
right
and you still don't i mean you're not
supposed to but um
so after graduating he tried off a bunch
of different pro teams
while he worked in a slaughterhouse oh
god it's a rocky
it's a rocky uh thing oh sure well
that's a scene i've always loved in
rocky where you're like oh cool she's
got a bunch of
cow bodies for the shoot huh their lives
were worthwhile
thank you for that well i'm sure someone
ate them afterwards do you think they
were
like that was what they were doing like
after sylvester stallone is [ __ ]
wailing on it for three
yeah who was a rib eye yeah yeah
who was this on a rump roast what
who that was a rump roast or something
what y'all i've been punching all did
you see how to punch out a cow today
the pot i punched
earlier today i punched out a cows what
yeah
do you want to eat it now i don't know
what you're saying let's eat those
and the chicken i chased is that english
i'm going to eat them now
yo you
uh so
he's in the slaughterhouse he's working
he's trying out for different teams
uh and then casey stengel is the manager
of the oakland oaks and he
is casey segal goes on to be one of the
greatest oaks yeah okay
it's better than oakland a's i think
it's close to oakland oh it's it's not
great oaks
well there's a californian oak tree
state
okay oakland yeah dumb
do we really want to do this yeah i'm
ready
you're real billy martin i don't care
so casey single he's going to go on to
be one of the greatest managers of all
time okay
so he's right now he's with the oaks and
uh
he comes by and and he casey singles
like this guy
is just [ __ ] ridiculous like his his
one pants legs up and he's just filthy
and he
it doesn't fit he he's like i've never
seen anything like this guy
okay uh and then he ends up signing him
wow
to the oakland oaks they they
immediately try to put a no fighting
clause in his contract because he has a
reputation
right smart and billy refused to sign
the contract with a notebook
i mean so that's not like a great
admission right you're like i feel like
this guy's gonna get us in a lot of
trouble
i love that he all he wants to do is
play baseball and then yeah and
negotiating like those deals like
all the concessions you have to make
along the way to get more money or
whatever it is but to have that be one
of your sticking points like
yeah so billy is not going to first of
all the money we finally got it where we
need it
again it's just that nagging clause that
um billy just doesn't feel comfortable
he's not saying he wants to fight he
just won't remove it from the option
list
so well that seems a little uh uh
giving him the option just the option he
wants the option
and i'll be honest the guy doesn't want
to fight he's [ __ ]
seems like he doesn't want him out of
his system so we just need this in there
you should sign it it's a sign of good
faith it's a sign of good faith that you
trust him to not fight
yeah it doesn't really just to trust him
to not fight he wants the freedom to do
it and not to do it
you know that's what he wants and he
wants he wants to know that you have his
back in that way
i i'm more confused fighting isn't what
he wants to do he's involved
he's a ball player but he's a ball
player he hits meat in a
in a warehouse where he gets it out of
his system it's all in this it's all in
the stakes
that's all that's that's behind him now
that's in the stakes
he put all that into those stakes
okay yeah i mean you make i guess it
makes sense okay great
i've never been this confused yeah well
he's going to fight a lot of people all
right so let's get in here for the
signing
so he refused to sign it and they
they've got so many injuries they need
short stop in second baseman the
infielders so they they agree to it they
give in okay
um he he he is you know he's in a really
bad brawl in his first season it's kind
of like
every player just basically already has
like the no fighting thing like you're
just like
it's it's it should be yeah so you
gather that someone's like
like hey don't fight it's obviously not
what we're here for um
so he plays in the minors he is named
the league's mvp in 1947. he's a good
player he doesn't look like a baseball
player he looks like just like a
scrawny dude so the next year he gets
brought up to the oakland oaks the
majors and he's playing for casey
stengel and they they quickly form like
a
father-son bond okay but billy doesn't
play much
sure um what casey had him do
what it's almost his role on the team
was he
he would just stand on the steps of the
dugout and scream at the opposing team
oh so he was just like he's just like
all-time fighter
he was there to just [ __ ] with them okay
because casey starting agitator
here's your dick starting agitator
and tonight's [ __ ] face is billy martin
laying it at 140
with one pant on one pant leg off
the only guy who's allowed to
technically fight on the team
[ __ ] talking martin
what's that the first th first th
[ __ ]
yes uh
so wait the reason casey did this
because he he wanted the intensity level
of the game
to be taken up she wanted everyone to be
on edge intense right and like that was
his style that's how he like to manage
billy's also a big drinker which casey
stengel really liked casey did not like
sober players
right of course not no i when it comes
to athletes you want them a little
off you want them dull you didn't trust
anybody who didn't drink yeah it's a red
flag
you know they're focused purely on the
sport like can you imagine in athletics
like being
like looking for the players who like to
drink it's just so
counter over but back then it was
normal it's just like yeah
it's just how we dealt with everything
you got a bad heart you shouldn't move
uh no i'm good okay
so so
around this time uh he meets
lois uh burnt who becomes his girlfriend
this is like first really big i've never
seen anyone yell like you i can i
are we going to make love now i mean i
well i would be rewarding you for bad
behavior so no
be rude to other people but to me be
sweet when i'm inside of you
i'll keep building to you billy you gave
up another home run billy
read the room
in 1949 casey became the yankees manager
okay
so he trades for billy who's just
starting shouter
we don't have one he chased for billy on
october 13th 1949. so right away that's
the guy he wants
but billy is not really is he playing
he's not really playing okay so he's
pretty much just there to shout and so
he's
because billy has a bit of a likes the
drink and is an all-time agitator he
yeah he's uh he's bringing in like who
are you thinking for shortstop he's like
it doesn't matter i need to figure out
who's going to be yelling it's like
you've got to sign him
and also this guy can't have a no fight
clause in his contract
yeah it was like phil jackson always had
a dick right right right like some guy's
like a dick on the team yeah
so uh when he got traded for the new
york writers are like what the [ __ ] why
would you want this guy who never plays
um the yankees already had a second
baseman shortstop so they're like what
are you yeah but he can't shout worth a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
so his mom jenny gives him advice when
he's leaving
quote don't let any of those [ __ ] new
york big shots
give you any [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
how to [ __ ] play baseball just as
[ __ ] good as they do jesus christ
i love you mom yeah you don't have much
of a shot to be like a calm person when
that's like the person who's been in
your corner your whole life
yeah so yeah that's that's the person
that was in this corner i definitely
like to picture the music swelling
billy just one more thing yeah ma don't
take no
[ __ ] from those [ __ ] new york pieces
of [ __ ] you know how to play ball better
than any of those [ __ ] wits
[ __ ] him and [ __ ] you he's like okay
okay mommy
get on that bus uh so he got there he's
scared [ __ ] list because
you know it's the yankees this is a
solid team of amazing player you know
dimaggio and all these amazing players
yeah there's somebody oh wow yeah he
doesn't really look like much of a ball
player
he doesn't at all no um he's so he
looks like the guy who like grabs the
bats when the players are done
the bat boy yeah uh so he's
like i said he's scared shitless when he
gets there but he becomes the first
player in
mlb history to get two hits in the his
the first two at-bats
okay uh he becomes really good friends
with yankee great joe dimaggio
who you know if you don't know joe
dimaggio married marilyn monroe
like set a record that he'll never be
broken like um
really amazing player yeah and he takes
billy marrying most out of his league
yes right uh so he takes billy around
manhattan and just introduces him to all
the celebrities and all the
you know right the elite people and
women of course
um but he still doesn't play much right
casey has him
just screaming at the other team wow
it's weird that joe dimaggio's like yeah
this guy's great
so he must have been like very you he
must have been charismatic to some
extent like there must be
yeah he must have been steering drive
some kind yeah a billy does have a
magnetic quality about him
it's also there's like those people who
like i've been friends with over the
years where people are like why are you
friends
and you're like i just am like there's
good good friends bad enemies
i'm right here i know yeah i didn't want
to say your name you were really ruined
by your dad
uh so he gets sent to the miners the the
gm of the team
is like what the [ __ ] um it's not
casey's call
he sends him down he cries he's so
upset and casey when he's crying says
look it was the gm's decision so billy
storms up to the the general manager's
office
jesus who's the guy if you don't know
he's the guy who runs the team he picks
all the players
big boss he runs up the team and screams
at him and says quote you'll be sorry
for this
oh god which is what his mom told him to
do yeah but it's still
in practice it really means a lot more
he goes down to the minors he tears it
up he's back in the month
like he's too good to keep in the minors
okay
yankees win the world series that year
wow like they they average they average
about
13 000 a year as salary but then if they
won the world series they
everybody got 5700 so that was a really
big deal right right
like they would they would yell stuff
like if a guy wasn't hustling they'd be
like don't [ __ ] with my money
right like it like really i want to get
back to that that direct
version of it where it's like you're all
playing for your bucks now
literally so
um oh
right so the yankees win the world
series okay
billy did not play at all but he gets
the cash um sure
and then he marries lois okay uh
so he shows up to the uh wedding
in baseball cleats oh what
like if you're joe dimaggio maybe but
he's not playing baseball he's not
playing he loves bass but he's not
playing that's like what a child does
it's like when a kid dresses up like the
garbage man
like he's just shouting he doesn't need
cleats to shout uh
yeah i mean it's not he loves baseball
sure but he's not playing baseball
really he's just shouting a lot
well lois made him change before uh the
wedding he used someone else's shoes
okay good so he really was like this
will happen he didn't bring a backup
pair
though so he gets so the korean war is
on this draft
and he gets a hardship discharge to get
out of the draft
i can't i'm have cleat foot i god
someone's gotta take
care of the cleats and the woman only
take these
so people are mad at okay because
it's it's it doesn't look good you're a
yankee you get out of the draft
it's not yeah this is before like
everybody
you know tried to dodge combat service
like you know
well i mean rich people always did but
yeah um
but he says he's the sole family earner
which which works people are upset by
that right that like
oh it's a yankee avoiding the draft
right but he becomes a starting second
baseman because
the other one goes well he got drafted
the other one got drafted
pretty great i mean it's working out
great
yeah yeah oh it's so good
i mean i'm sure i didn't read but that
should must have made people even more
mad oh yeah
yeah well i guess i'll have to play
because the other one's serving so
is that crazy um so
casey thinks the team is soft and they
don't have a leader because joe
dimaggio's retired and
he's like this is just so who's a
firecracker in-house
so in may at the beginning of the season
they're in boston
which is their big rival and a rookie on
boston starts mouthing off to the
yankees before the game while they're
warming up
sure and the yankees as professional
world series champions
just focus lock in and play the game
that's right
well the rookie ends up calling billy a
quote
[ __ ] busher okay he's italian and then
butcher bush league
okay bush league meaning you're you know
you're like not
poor here you're not four here you're
lame you do [ __ ] stuff
um so billy is like let's fight you want
to [ __ ] fight
okay let's go under the grandstands and
beat the [ __ ] out of each other sure
yeah let's that's
that's where i'd be like i'm not looking
for like a private fight i'd rather do
it in front of these guys that can break
it up
well they all go down there the team the
teams go to watch professional baseball
teams go under the bleachers to watch
these two fights yeah yeah okay
yeah and billy just beats a little [ __ ]
out of them like
just he's barely conscious blood is
pouring out of his nose
like he's just and so when casey hears
i think reporters tell him or something
all he did was smile
and he told reporters well billy's fire
is going to spread on this team oh my
god that's not a good fire
we're gonna beat up on the whole boston
red sox and organization
from top to bottom it's baseball you
beat the [ __ ] out of another guy under
the grandstand that's good i want i'm
looking for a bunch of violent guys
that's what i mean really violent
really really psychotically violent
gentleman i i mean i basically have you
seen rollerball i want to combine
rollerball and baseball i wish i could
take all of billy's bad habits and put
it in each one of my guys
so here's what i'm doing uh i am uh he's
gonna have
a sock full of marbles when he's out on
the we're gonna call them marbles we're
leaning in as jersey's gonna say it
you come at second base billy is gonna
he's not even gonna have a glove he's
just gonna have a satchel of marbles
he's just beating anyone with
crack yep i wanna see blood i'm gonna
see brains on the dirt
we are gonna bury bodies in the mound
anyway that's our plan for this year all
right
so after that i mean right after the
fight they go on a winning streak
okay now the rookie turned out
the one that billy bart beat up he
turned out to actually have mental
issues
oh okay cool all right that's cool well
that ages really well
great okay and
billy felt really bad when he heard that
so for the rest of his life billy would
always give him jobs to help him he
became friends with him and wow he would
always take care of him okay
all right yeah and you brought it back
you won me back
so lois lois gets pregnant but
he's not paying attention to her because
he's hanging out hold it in that's what
they did with me
go 11 months i'll be back by then
he's hanging out with mickey mantle now
mickey mantle is a notorious boozer
honest i don't know why
i thought you were gonna say mickey
mouse he's saying mickey mouse i was
just like what is he doing like yeah
come on billy let's pick the [ __ ] out of
these guys [ __ ] the [ __ ] these pugs i'm
hammered
i can't drive can you drive wait is my
dick out
oh i got arrested for jerking off in
public
hey you ever see a mouse
oh i started trying to sell angel dust
to a cop
i fought a cop's horse
i would pay to watch uh mickey mouse
fight a cop's horse yeah
here they are oh yeah so there's
dimaggio oh
sorry there's uh billy and and mickey
mouse no so these guys are these guys
two gentlemen like to drink
uh-huh mickey mouse notorious boozer
okay notorious
okay so uh so they're hanging out
together
um so both of their wives are like
feeling neglected
and they they move back home i don't
know where lois's home was but she goes
back to her like her hometown and
is like okay well if you're not gonna
pay attention to me i'm gonna go back to
my family
um so when when the war ends
fights in major league baseball increase
dramatically
so it's all these guys coming back with
ptsd oh wow and then they're just
[ __ ] brawling on the field right
jesus
and the yankees are huge drinkers
and huge fighters right well i mean
their coach
basically wanted both yeah no he's no
problem
right during one i mean not just on the
field they would go
into town and get into fights in bars
like they were sure
bar brawlers sure during one fight
a yankee held a broken bottle to a
bouncer's neck
as they all escaped out the back door
good lord so they're not [ __ ] around
no
in the 1952 season a player billy had
fought in the miners
came sliding in with his spikes up so
right he's got his cleats on he's trying
to hurt
the guy who's at second base and billy
retaliates
the next time he tries it and hits him
in the face with his glove really hard
knocking him down
okay the player then charges
billy and billy punches him twice in the
face
oh my god and then a massive brawl
breaks out between both teams
okay and at the end billy had to be
pulled off quote
like a madman oh god and then his
pictures
the pictures of this fight you can see
him like like doing an uppercut you can
actually see it
they're in papers nationwide and now
he's labeled the brawler
yes well yeah yeah justifiably so oh of
course yeah yeah
that that move just clocking again
the picture is just wow amazing yeah so
after that um
he's now a leader on the team sure and
he signs a really lucrative contract so
now he's a really good player so
really i know what did was was everyone
rewarding
this level of uh it wasn't frowned upon
fighting yeah no it's assault fighting
is not frowned upon
okay um so yeah so
they don't care i mean the truth is when
you think about like hockey like that's
basically what hockey has it's just kind
of this like
yeah guess what if you go to a high game
you're probably going to see dudes fight
each other at the game yeah that's right
so it's just kind of that
it's that sort of thing like there's
just a lot of brawls it is weird that
hockey is like hey we
we've never tried to figure that i know
they yeah wayne gretzky people love it
gretes could always be like
we shouldn't have this and they'd be
like no way hey come on wayne lighten up
you just don't fight if you don't want
to
i mean they had to have a bodyguard for
wayne gretzky on the ice they
mcsorley was his bodyguard every team he
was on had a bodyguard if you went and
hit wayne gretzky you were going to no
they were
they were the kings but they actually
had every monarch like they had a whole
echelon of power yeah there was the duke
i don't blame them
[Laughter]
so um so he signs your contract they win
the world series
billy's the hero for a catch he makes in
uh so he's now a household name across
the country right he's now a household
baseball player it also sets a bad
precedent for coaches who are like you
just got to beat the [ __ ] out of each
other
it's not great yeah um so this all
causes him at lowe's to drift even
further apart
six weeks after she gives birth good
uh she gives him divorce papers
good that's good and babies lo that's
good stuff
that's good babies love that that's good
that's the age when you're supposed to
do it
yeah yeah no the best time uh to
separate as a parent is before your
trauma doesn't affect a child till four
that's right so
uh whitey ford joins the yankees whitey
ford
is a notorious drinker okay uh came up
in the oh god what's his name
beardy the minor league guy that we did
the baseball episode on the minor league
guy oh yeah yeah
he was a big okay he was a big brother
buddy fork so
is he just like a super white dude i
don't know why his name is whitey
ford i guess he's super white like he's
gotta be crazy you he was a
culture sleep team right
same thing uh so whitey's just
i mean we're all white but he's super
white
so whitey billy and mickey mantle just
spent drunken nights
uh in new york and the media would
follow them and just write about their
antics
okay billy refused to open
any letters from lois's lawyer because
he is a catholic he's a practicing
catholic he goes to church all the time
he's a
practicing catholic and he doesn't
believe in door
that looks such a it's a there's just
you really can get away with lot
a lot of them
really play it nice and loose like look
don't get divorced like can i beat the
[ __ ] out of people and be drunk all the
time yeah do not get divorced
you understand me uh his grandmother
dies
uh it's very upsetting so that day in a
game he gets into a fight
sure with the same guy got into the
fight with before oh that's cool
kind of full circle um this one's for
you
nana this is for my grams
she was the best uh the league report
said
it took quote several minutes and
multiple umpires
to subdue billy martin i mean several
minutes in fight time
is an hour 45 minutes yeah it's crazy
it's
a different time yeah like minutes
he would have been an amazing uh ufc
fighter oh god
that's the very first punch that's the
newspaper shot that went around the
country
it feels like that guy already has a
black eye and looks a lot like zippo
marks i mean he just
he's it's he it is him decking the guy
yeah he just decided
yeah i figured he was
[Music]
uh but with that punch his feet left the
ground yeah so he's doing like a mike
tyson's punch-out he gives it all and
he'll fight guys bigger than him he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
uh so opposing opposing fans start
heckling billy about his divorce
oh okay so he's getting [ __ ] the
catholic church no longer recognizes you
your wife doesn't want to be married to
you
you have been one of the lead roles of
catholicism
yo the pope hates you now dude
the pope don't hate you you're gonna get
kicked out of your church
cardinals won't even take your call
uh the chicago newspaper reports that he
was a deadbeat dad and not paying any
money
to lois which is a total lie right they
just made it up okay
it goes national sure it's a huge story
um you know it got so people are giving
him [ __ ] it got so bad that he was
in uh st patrick's cathedral
praying and another guy in the parish
walks by and said quote if you're a
member of this parish then i quit
wow they beat the snot out of him with
like the guys
i think i think it's uh yeah you want to
go in that hole
so casey then set the record straight
and he told reporters the yankees
actually sent his
part of his paychecks to lois so it's
all [ __ ] okay
so billy billy's having his best season
ever he's just playing great baseball
they win the world series against jesus
christ
back to back to back i they won a few in
a row i mean they the yankees back then
were a machine sure
um so after they win the world cup
you're being like validated in the fact
that your players should be alcoholics
and fighters
like it's going great
that's really cool you know it's like
it's like a build through the draft
philosophy but it's like
yeah these guys are psychos
[Laughter]
so after uh after he wins world series
he goes
to mickey mantle lives on a in a small
town somewhere
sure and uh he goes to visit him and
they go to a local farm because they
want to hunt and the mickey's going to
ask the
ghost to ask the farmer he goes can we
hunt on your land just a random
farmer i think he knows him okay um so
the farmer goes yes
but he tells mickey can you
shoot my mule because it's gone blind
and lame and i can't
i can't bring myself to shoot it oh wow
and so mickey's like sure
can we hunt it kind of meet in the
middle
i mean you can hide it with a bat it's
just great it's it's blind and lame
great that's what we'll do let it loose
and we'll go in the forest and beat it
with a bat today there's no loose like
it's
blind and lame like we'll push it into a
field somewhere and then we'll try to
find it
it's not i mean it's lame come on let's
make a day of it no i mean you're
literally
to hunt it you can just walk up i don't
even want to hear this
don't give me any insights into it i
just want to find it
it's right there it's in the it's it's
laying down
over there i can't see anything it's
laying all right
we're going to blow it up with dynamite
so mickey decides to do a prank
and he runs out of the house furious
yelling that the farmer had said no they
can't oh jesus christ he
shoots the mule jesus christ is that
some dark [ __ ]
and then he hears two shots and turns
around
and billy has shot two cows and billy
says quote that bastard should we shoot
more
wait wait wait
why why oh no
oh no oh
i could just don't prank him in that way
oh my god you imagine the farmer the
[ __ ] what's going on that'll teach you
to insult mickey mantle i thought
that one was blind also with the other
ones and the other one
sorry sir i didn't explain to my friend
here that i was pulling a prank and he's
a
lunatic so now you have four dead cows
the one you wanted and three newbies
uh on january 15th let's go kill that
farmer
billy belly billy barber is boss let's
go
on january 15th so i skinned the farmer
i i assume they're both shit-faced when
that happens okay
i mean that's just i think you can
assume that for most billy martin mickey
mantle stories
sure on uh january and mickey mantle
he's the home run king oh like yeah he's
like he had a record for years
so he's like a big player so on january
15 1954
billy's hardship deferral was withdrawn
so
i'm not sure if he withdrew it or if the
the military was like oh
you're you're gonna get drafted he won
the purple hardship yes he won the
purple he
he goes and he serves 18 months um all
in the u.s he doesn't have to go
overseas
that's and the yankees what an exotic
place to end up oh my god could you
imagine
i mean just you and for san diego
um yankees are terrible without them
they immediately turn to [ __ ]
wow when he comes back they go on a run
and they make
is he hitting a lot of home runs and
stuff or he
this is just a real role-playing pulse
of the team player
he i think that he has an energy that he
drives the team
right you know but he's not like like
he's very good
right yeah especially on defense but he
hits well he's a good guy he's a very
good baseball player he's just not a
home run here but
but there's the guys who get on base
sure yeah yeah as long as he's one of
those guys
otherwise it's just it's so crazy no no
he's a he's a very good baseball player
okay
um and so so he comes back
and they immediately go on a run and go
to the world series they lose but
that's what that's what he brings like
he's right
he finally signs the divorce papers so
what's it been like two years or
something
[ __ ] crazy oh god must have been
furious oh god
i'm trading you this is not what i plan
you're going to the jew team um so now
he's an older player on the team he's
been around a while
he's a vet he's hanging out with
celebrities rocky marciano sinatra
oh so like the good and like good
influence right right guys who like
are going to teach them about
temperament and yeah the sweet yeah the
guys who are
surrounded by pacifists right right
yo billy cut his nose off all right
frank
uh billy's a ladies man
now back then there is booze in every
locker room
of course no these are professional
athletes there's like a bar and like
absolutely you need to
play baseball you know like most
athletes now they play better after
they've had a few
men look great it would be to have your
up like the other team believing in
drinking when you had like none you'd be
like this is gonna be great
i i years ago preseason game
uh i went to see the rangers
the scotland rangers play the la galaxy
and i was in a suite with some fancy
people and one of the guys is like i was
like why are the rangers so bad and he
goes
oh no they're shit-faced they were out
drinking at a pub all day um
yeah that must be that's totally what
you would do if you were like an english
club or any like
any of those clubs coming to the states
and remember your boys have to have
three drinks before my team will play
them
that's so crazy um so look
there's boost in the locker room uh free
drinks in the stadium press lounges so
the journalists are booze pretty much
players coach reporters they all drink
they drink together
everyone drinks it's just drinky time
except
the yankees gm the general manager who
billy yelled at yeah
like i gotta stay sober a man's trying
to kill me so
he still hates billy martin and any time
any yankee gets in trouble
he blames billy okay and he thinks billy
billy is a bad fluence on mickey mantle
sure i doubt it like ricky mantle fine
on his own
right he hires private detectives to
follow billy martin around
okay wow this is and
how about you talk to him guy and he
keeps leaking to the press
that billy's a bad influence so it's
true he's trying to get the fans to turn
against billy but the fans are [ __ ]
pretty hard love billy martin right like
billy martin is
well he's that guy you look at me like
oh i can play baseball like he has the
physicality of you but and he's just
tenacious
the guy that just hustles and doesn't
give up right right
so they win the world series again jesus
and this guy's trying to get him off the
team but they're still doing well
because
i want to lose and it doesn't help that
when he was gone they were [ __ ]
yeah right and he's immediately good
again but he's trying to undermine him
and billy is still one of the big new
york celebrities right he's one of the
biggest libraries in new york his
his drinking partner becomes jackie
gleason okay
okey dokey i was i don't know much about
jackie gleason big drinker honeymooners
yeah big drinker
they became known for bar dares around
new york
they would balance shot glasses on their
heads while jumping or leaping from the
floor to a bar stool without spilling
the drink
what what kind of
could you so this is from the
perspective of
if if it was today right right so you go
into
you go into a bar and mike trout
and uh who's the biggest comedian today
um gosh dave anthony
and dave anthony no you want a big comic
name
you need a big comedian dave dave
chappelle
okay dave chappelle and well people
would believe it if it was japan
okay so you want a more a big comedian i
guess your pal is fine
brian regan so yeah you go into a bar
you go to a bar and mike trout and brian
regan
are putting shot glasses on their heads
and jumping up and down from bar stools
i would be a it'd be problematic you'd
see it on instagram
i mean tom brady got drunk after the
super bowl and it was like big news
that you shouldn't even be drunk you're
supposed to get drunk after the super
bowl yeah but it's still weird to see
like a great athlete like
so and that
and that again is okay billy is this is
kind of just like oh
celebrities did you ever watch mad men
it's that period
right where it's just all bets are off
there's booze in everyone's office like
everyone's just [ __ ] drinking right
right we gotta i mean don't you think
with all the
the culminating problems coming our way
that it's we're gonna be opening up the
booze
like the hours of boozing are you going
to get a little fudgy it might get you
you know what i mean you might open that
door
it'd like just be like yeah i started
drinking in the mornings anyway what's
up
do i need to stay sober today no it's
just okay cool yeah
so the gm brings billy into the office
and he says one more bad move and you're
gone
because this stuff's getting one more
world series you're out of here martin
but billy's like
seriously i'm billy martin like what the
[ __ ] you gonna get rid of me good
[ __ ] luck
on may 16th the yankees are celebrating
billy's 29th birthday
at the copa club and
boy and it's
it's a there's gangsters there it's like
it's a thing so
a group of junk bowlers from washington
heights come in and bill and
and billy's there with all his friends
bowlers bowlers okay
bowling group great sure just wanted to
make sure that we're
our bad guys are a group of bowlers a
league bowling squad walked in
and then things escalated when a group
of bowlers came by
sammy davis jr is performing and one of
them calls him
a little [ __ ] he yells it oh good okay
so martin and another yankee stand up
and they're like hey shut the [ __ ] up
right that's [ __ ] sammy davis jr and
then an enormous
brawl breaks out between the the yankees
and the bowlers and also the
the bouncers who are fighting the
bowlers also
sure one bowler gets hit so hard he has
a concussion a broken jaw and a broken
nose
front page news right
it turns out it was actually a bouncer
who punched the
the guy but the yankee right give that
guy a yankees uniform
he's perfect
the yankee right fielder is arrested and
put on trial okay
so during the trial mickey takes the
stand quote
i was so drunk i didn't know who threw
the first punch a body came flying and
landed at my feet at first i thought it
was billy so i picked him up
but when i saw it wasn't i dropped him
back down
it looked like roy rogers rode through
the coppa on a trip
on trigger and trigger kicked the guy in
the face
the jury laughed everybody laughed
that man almost died
another droll tale and a line of great
ones mickey god bless you
you are the heart of new york you're the
epitome of what this city stands
today i heard my favorite baseball
player describe a man being beaten
almost well
be fair he was guesstimating he was too
drunk to really remember the scene for
the love of god
our pro sports heroes uh the yankee was
acquitted
a month later that's my one-act play by
the way yeah a month later the yankees
get into a 30-minute
brawl with the white sox oh my god
exhausting a 30-minute fight
what are you doing could you imagine
watching that you're just like can we
get back to the baseball
ah guys he's dead he's dead already
who fights for 30 minutes geez how
exhausting is that
all right we're gonna take a break uh
the fight will be coming back
part two when we come back the bottom of
the fight
uh billy was suspended uh blamed for the
fight and the gm traded him three days
later okay
now he's he bleeds yankees like he is
a yankee and he's devastated he cries
he tells casey you let him down his
heart he's just heartbroken yeah
whitey and mickey cry in the locker room
like everyone's just bawling
other players cry too and billy billy
feels betrayed and bitter also
you know because the yankees got rid of
him and he has to go to kansas city
which is
oh so they were just from new york corn
fields yeah from new york to kansas city
and also kansas city sucks
this here is the city that always sleeps
a little bit different uh we got
celebrities
uh uh we got uh
jimmy the cow we uh for a couple days
had a dog he was the mayor he was not
allowed to enact any actual policies but
pretty much you and that dog are gonna
be the a-list in this team oh he'll
fight too
he's a fighter
i know you think we probably don't get
crazy here but we've been known to put
blueberries in our pancakes
so buckle up martin you ain't seen it
all
yet why is he crying
kane city had lost 94 games so it's the
opposite of the world series winning
yankees sure
he he starts drinking differently oh i
by the way
my one note is is this guy drinking the
right way
his sister's quote it wasn't like he was
drug a lot but a drink was more
important to him
so yeah so he's uh depressed
and because he's been kind of allowed to
just
be debaucherous all the time now he
doesn't really want to play ball anymore
so you're just kind of seeing like
since he's comfortable like he's
drinking at home now but that's just a
base
yeah basically and there's no no jackie
leeson louisiana's not coming to kansas
city right so he is it's now a
depressive
drink he's escaping he's escaping which
again is what you want in one of your
athletes on your team
numb the pain with booze yeah
uh he was never the same player after
getting traded he he
gets traded from team to team at one
point he dates a flight attendant
gretchen winkler and the press is all
over it
so twas just wanted to get out of there
he's like put me in the plane
so twa executives make sure that she's
on all of his flights
and and in towns he's staying in because
the press will cover it and then that's
that's coverage for twa
great and it worked out too
they end up getting married in 1959.
okay
in detroit uh fans didn't like him when
he was on the team there
in cleveland he has problems with the
manager he got
and then in cleveland he got hit in the
face with a fastball
a teammate quote i never saw a man look
so dead
he didn't flutter or move his face
swelled up
like a beehive in five minutes his face
was crushed there's bees in here
guys that's why they have this face
the queen's in his nose um
i never saw a man look so dead yeah so
so but
but probably like you know it's a
conflation of a few things really like
he's
depressed wow he's just drunk he didn't
get hit oh
he's saying he looks dead because he got
hit well i mean he's seth yeah i mean he
probably is like
[ __ ] it what's the point well like
because normally i'd be like that guy
would get up and fight the guy who threw
the faster yeah
unless he got hits a hearty i mean he's
probably just out but no i think it was
sad
talk to the doctor and now i can't tell
if he got hit by a fastball if he's just
sad
you can see from these x-rays he's just
pretty down
there's a i mean you can see obviously
the cheekbone is shattered and that'll
be
need to be redone but i'll tell you
there's something these x-rays aren't
showing
his emotional state he's low gentlemen
well this is a guy who plays in kansas
city
yeah uh his john cheekboner broken sure
he's out for two months
sure and then when he uh is reinstated
to a team they immediately trade him to
the cincinnati reds
okay but now he's scared to bat
yeah i get that for sure so all pitchers
quickly realize that and they throw up
and inside at him and he just keeps
flinching away from the ball
yeah and that's he knows like he it's
billy right
and he knows he's not the tough old
billy and and it goes on for a while
but then it's spring training the next
year right they take the summer
they take the winter break and he comes
back and
in spring training he gets into a bar
fight so it's like the old billy's
coming back right all right
all right he's still got some highlights
in him yeah
yeah he got into a fight last night all
right how about he beat the guy
up so uh after a chicago pitcher
threw inside billy pretended to lose his
grip on the next pitch and threw the bat
at the pitcher
oh man accidentally doing that is very
funny yeah
whoopsies and when he goes out to pick
up the bat
the pitcher walks up to him and billy
punches him in the jaw okay
all right we're back the pitch pitcher's
orbital bone was fractured and billy was
suspended for five games [ __ ] a
the cub sued him for two million dollars
and he ended up having to pay him 22 000
which is his whole salary for the year
well still could have been worse that's
crazy yeah
for sure oh is that it oh it's in the
okay yeah yeah it was mislabeled then
yeah that's probably
okay so that's just the side of a man's
orbital bone breaking
yeah okay um in 1962
he was playing for the twins and they
cut him and that was it he sat in the
locker room and cried he was done as a
baseball player and billy you're gonna
have to
cry outside we need that locker hate to
be that guy but
so the twins heard him as a scout okay
and uh so now he's going on the country
looking
for i don't know if this guy needs the
road
well he also got a job as a uh as a
beer salesman so he's so he's now he's a
scout with free beer and he's a drunk
yeah so he goes into bars and buys
everybody drinks and
it's hey by the way before i go i got
something anybody here
hit any of you guys ever played a
baseball in any capacity i'm supposed to
be scouting today i forgot though
what's that whoo i can't believe i got
to repeat that okey-dokey
i also came here because i'm supposed to
find a guy who can play balls
anyone hear a really good baseball who
can swing them out
somebody say something somebody say
something i agree
yes oh you can play you're pretty
old how old are you 48. that's pretty
old but okay that's pretty good you want
to sign a deal to be the twins and
you're starting bat boy
man yeah okay great he signed it
to she's on here
okay all right welcome aboard see the
stadium
what's the beer you have uh i really
remember honestly so there's a lot of
a lot of jobs all of a sudden it's just
too many jobs honestly
i should have taken it
easier in new york
[Applause]
it got very real who screwed me over so
bad is that gay
hey okay hi yeah sorry i dipped out for
a minute is everything all right
yeah all right you got tears coming down
yeah i'm crying pretty bad right now
this is hard to beat me okay
so um he and gretchen have a son
and uh the twins make him the third base
coach
and then he's not a very long
base coach keeps signaling defeat he's
not a very long drunken flight
okay and with the twins team and
he gets in an argument with the twins
traveling secretary the guy who books
all the stuff and handles all the
travel and stuff yeah yeah and
they keep arguing after the plane lands
on the way to the hotel
and in line checking in and then the guy
checks billy in last
so billy punches him in the face okay
sure
and now billy had been on track to
become the twins manager but now
right he's not attractive right yes and
they make him a minor league manager
instead they're like okay
go down there yeah well i'm sure the
travel will be a lot worse
so the team is the team is [ __ ]
terrible and
so he takes like a casey stengel page
so he's okay he wants to put the other
team under pressure any way he can
so he would have he would do stuff like
one guy would be running
from first to second and he would fake
tr he would fake like he fell
and then all the players would look at
him and then the guy on third would run
and score
okay like he's doing this crazy it's
just all that kind of stuff
strict plays and [ __ ] with people and
and the pressure would cause the other
team
to make mistakes and then become
embarrassed that they made a mistake so
it's like this double like
and then and then the team would slowly
unravel and no one's seen anything like
this like no one's ever done this
right it's just totally first billy's
thing
and people start to [ __ ] love it and
he also starts arguing with umps a lot
and he would kick dirts on them and dirt
on them like you go out and kick
kick dirt at their shoes and he got
ejected from eight games but the team
starts to win and fans start flocking
because
it's it's this crazy version right
and then he gets named the minnesota
twins manager
the traveling secretary was like my
resignation letter is tender
and they were good but they became
really good on her billy
now the owner demanded that billy meet
him twice a week for a meaning to
discuss
everything that was happening with the
team sure and billy was like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] and the guy was like just
any time during the day except for
between 5 and 5 30.
so billy would show up between 5 and 5
30. now where is he and the guy be like
this is when i take my nap come back
and then he come the next day between 5
and 5 30 until the guy
finally gave up wow it stopped asking
the cup i love a 5 to 5 30 nap locked
into your schedule i know right it's
great i love everything about this i
love a 5 to 5 30 nap and i love the
other guy coming at five to five yeah
that's great
it's all the whole scenario yeah well i
mean look when you give us an adult your
nap time they're gonna work you know
they can work you
yes uh come back around 5 45 i'm gonna
have graham crackers and milk
billy has a starting pitcher run uh 20
laps
before games sure right exhaust you
before you play
but there's this pitcher dave boswell
and he
he's like i'm not [ __ ] doing that i'm
not going to run 20 [ __ ] laps yeah
and the pitching coach goes and tells
billy dave boswell's not
going to run and then boswell obviously
hears about that and he's [ __ ] pissed
of the pitching coach
so they're all drinking at a bar and of
course roswell and the pitching coach go
outside the bar in the alley and
and get into a fight and
uh it's just like if any of these things
happened it would just be enormous news
yes now you know it's just like like
you'd be like what the [ __ ]
yeah so he knocks the pitching coach out
and then billy rushes out and just
starts wailing on boswell till he was
unconscious
so then he'd be like it's just you
shouldn't
injure your players it's just not how
you got to though because now it's
coaches against players
you guys here we're fighting the coaches
what we're fighting the coaches
so billy knocks about and billy goes
with him to the hospital you know
because it's his player that he knocked
out
he's got to make sure he's okay he just
like switched hats he's like all right
now i'm the manager
we gotta get that looked at you wake up
he's holding your hand oh are you okay
yeah you beat me up some guy beat you up
no you did yeah
but now we're really bad yeah real bad
you knocked me out you think you can
play this thursday
yeah i'll play i'm always ready to play
that's my guy i need a team full of
fighters like you
boss only 26 pitching coach is dead oh
yeah
well i mean that he was a snitch
replaceable
yeah uh so he needs 20 stitches and
reporters
reporters asked billy what happened
quote well when he came off the wall i
hit him again
what the [ __ ] this is a manager
i'm not a wrestler he came off the wall
a manager beating a player unconscious
is national news like that's actually
yeah okay yeah i mean if they just
fought probably not but national news if
you beat him unconscious yeah
after he beat up his pitching coach yeah
so
and the owner the owner made boswell go
and apologize to billy
of course
at times it feels like a baseball team
and at other times it feels like a
middle school
hey so i just i i wanted to say i'm
sorry for you
for you beating me uncomfortable you
really owe me a big i'm sorry
i know i'm how dare you you i'm sorry
for your fist hitting me
when i close my eyes sometimes i still
hear your screams
uh yeah i apologize for the screaming
and the bleeding on your
fist you just it wasn't you that day
look i i said i'm sorry and i i just
don't do it again
no i don't plan to it wasn't great i got
to be honest
i can't go through that again you cannot
put me through that again
okay coach i'm i'm sorry i didn't mean
for you to beat me up be professional
from now on okay yeah
you can't go out there beating up a
coach well that
no i disagree with that that he he was a
snitch and uh
you know there's rules all right yeah
but still from now on learn your lesson
lead by example
that's what i always lead by example
you okay you want a manhattan yeah
okay we got a game soon let's get nice
and loose
so the twins the twins make it to the
playoffs
but they lose and billy's like
i publicly asked for a raise because he
did so well
sure and then a week later he heard on
the radio that he had been fired okay
sure exactly good
now fans are [ __ ] pissed right
an effigy of the owner is hung downtown
so they're effigy pissed
the local teamsters threatened to
boycott all
all twins games state legislators
petition the owner to reconsider
like everybody just [ __ ] loses
everyone who had a set of twins during
that time got rid of
everybody yes the owner does not budge
he's absolutely not doing it he hires
another manager
the next year attendance falls by 88
000.
okay but billy's been hired to manage
the detroit tigers
also a very bad team in his first game
an opposing player is he's very
flamboyant
shall we say he has on a tight tailor
uniform
a fu manchu mustache and colored
wristbands
okay again this is the 50s right so it's
a different look
uh right away billy starts yelling at
him of course right when the game starts
right quote you clown harrelson where
are your bell bottoms you think your
clothes are gonna hide the fact that you
can't catch anything the dirt anymore
everybody knows you can't hit a
curveball you're washed up you should
get off the field go
sit with your designer in some disco
that's where you belong
and his teammate billy's team are just
like this guy's [ __ ] crazy like
what's happening
the manager after they they lose that
game
and then afterwards the players are in
the clubhouse and they're eating
lunch and billy comes in and he calls
them all [ __ ] losers
and he says how can you be [ __ ]
eating right now and he flips over the
table with all the food on it
might have been maybe our first table
flipping a lot yeah
yeah he's definitely been picked up on
and he kicks the table and kicks the
food
quote there was chicken in the lockers
coleslaw and guy's shoes
beans on clothing but what they soon
realized
was that he saw it as us versus them he
seizes a war
right he's like we're going in a [ __ ]
war every day well it wouldn't be smart
to burn your rash into the war i mean to
be honest but yes i understand
it's us versus them yeah and we are a
team and there's no taking a look
lost lightly like it's all it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] so he teaches them to hate losing
he teaches them right and a miss
coleslaw and then miss call slide equal
side of shoes yeah like there's a hole
right they win the division okay
but they lose in five games billy cries
uh
the next season during the game billy
wants the umps to check a pitcher for
cheating
sure and they refuse to do it they're
like we're not [ __ ]
billy will handle this well so he has
his pitchers
cheat by using vaseline uh really
billy's like their pitcher's cheating
since they won't search him will cheat
will cheat
and then after that after that game he
tells the reporters about it
we cheated we [ __ ] cheated and he
said
he says why why he did it he says the
umps are [ __ ]
and they're not enforcing the rules so
the league
suspends him okay and he is fired
by the twins wait by the tigers yeah
that's all right right okay right right
again fans [ __ ] lose their [ __ ]
okay calls flood the tigers front office
people are
i really i really love the move it's
like he's like oh [ __ ] i thought that
would work
people are protesting outside the
stadium anywhere the owner goes
anywhere in detroit people are just
[ __ ] screaming at him
like it's a disaster but the texas
rangers
immediately hire billy like he when he
gets fired he gets hired within days
because
everybody [ __ ] loves them right okay
now texas only cares about football it's
[ __ ] football state so billy
billy is brought there to get attention
right he starts wearing cowboy outfits
he grows a mustache
i'd love to get back into that in one
second dave but uh
so as far as like the competency as a
manager
is that because he's obviously doing
well the teams are doing well
but if you're bringing a guy and have a
mustache or a cowboy like
how much of it is the flare and how much
of it is
the substance the substance is
there are people that say there never
has been or ever will be a coach like
him
right so it is he can see everything
happening on the
field at once right and figure out the
one thing
the weakness he is he's a genius right
okay
okay he's also crazy he's a [ __ ]
right box of like chickens he's a mad
genius yeah
so texas higherism um
texas is where he turned arguing in
umpires like his signature
thing okay everyone needs a thing yeah
so fans would come
two games just to see him flip out on
umpires
right kicks dirt on him he would throw
his hat
he would throw all the bats out of the
dugout and fans would cheer and
everybody loved it
sure he's got a set list yeah yeah uh he
was thrown out of both games of a double
header
one time okay and he was
twice that season tossed before the
games even started
happen just wow walking by well you know
they they walk out there yeah right
coaches walk out to exchange lineups and
he must have started talking
[ __ ] and getting right okay
um this is also the year of tencent beer
night in cleveland
okay right oh yeah right he was the
rangers coach yes and that's who they
played
and so the rangers had to fight their
way off off the field right and
afterwards billy
was thrilled that his team stuck
together and fought together
so was billy the only guy happy on
that went great that was amazing that
was fantastic boys that's how we got to
play every night
every night we're going to offer a 10
cent ale we need a riot
every single game all right
so the rangers finish in second but the
next year um they're bad
uh he starts drinking more and more and
more
that probably helped yeah oh yeah for
sure
you know coach has been really good
since he's been getting drunk
what's good he's obviously got some
really
crazy ideas i like it a lot he told me
to shoot a cow
yeah yeah no he told me to do that too i
just figured that was
some sort of like tell me
i'm not it might be a code yeah maybe
steal seconds
did you see what he wrote with on the
mirror and his puke no
win but he spelled it with a y but still
uh so plane flights were described as
flying saloons and casinos
jesus and he would fly with his
mistresses
okay so obviously gretchen is no longer
his uh
no she's still this is yeah but she's
not the flight attendant
no she's not the flight attendant she's
not married and probably at home and now
he's
billy loves to fly i love billy
uh the owner didn't sign a player billy
wanted
and then billy and the owner start
having issues oh that's good and if
you're the owner
you're entering dangerous territory fyi
oh yeah
so you've now you've now kicked the
hornet's nest yeah or poked it
wait you can do whatever the hornet's
nest no you poke it you should not kick
it if you can kick it you can kick
really high yeah but that's fine if you
can i mean if you have skills
yeah it's like poke the bear don't kick
them or you kick the bear i wouldn't
kick the right
nuts take that
also so billy wanted the stadium to play
john denver's
thank god i'm a country boy during the
seventh inning stretch because he just
got into country music in texas
uh-huh now the oh that is everywhere is
that most people's gateway countries
man i finally just heard it makes so
much sense
shane twain here i come the owner
what's the griddle the owner did not
want that song played in seven stretch
he wanted the traditional take me out to
the ballgame and they argued about it
all year long it's just not worth it
billy
and one day billy told reporters the
owner quote knows
as much about baseball as i know about
my pipe
the follow-up will be how much does he
know about his pipe
it feels like probably a good amount a
lot i know a lot okay so he's
okay i'm sort of a pipe expert okay so
you're saying it's a compliment it's a
compliment oh okay
it just felt like it had no no i was
saying yeah i mean i
i went to school and studied pipes oh my
god i have a degree in pipes
it sounds like you have a great
relationship yeah we're the best right
okay really great
the owner tells billy he's thinking of
firing him how complicated is a pipe
pretty much just like like
something with two holes in it yeah it's
really not a good analogy it's really
not
i don't understand these pipes serve it
like a maze to me
how do you unlock these things yeah
stupid dick
smoke smoke you smoke
so the next day after billy makes that
comment the
miller says he's right thinking about
firing him
in the sixth inning they have a phone in
the dugout
and billy billy calls what player you
need brought up billy no it's not player
no song we're making a change in the
lineup song wise
he calls whoever's in control of playing
the music
on the phone and the umpire heard billy
screaming to the phone quote
i don't care what the owner says play
the [ __ ] john denver song oh my god
imagine be like sitting there being like
this is the coach
like a bummer like i really want to win
[Music]
it's called a designated song yeah it's
a substitution
and billy said he better hear that song
or else
and then the song is played the owner's
like
he immediately fires billy
you know dave life ain't nothing but a
funny funny riddle
and after the game he cried and said
goodbye to the players oh my lord
sorry guys it's just that um
i don't know if you've ever heard take
me out to the ball game but it doesn't
have a lot of resonance
well people like it a lot actually shut
up charles
in all stadiums shut up a song that is
better
and is more connected to the root of the
city that we play in
thank god i'm a country boy and i had to
lay it it could don't look like
it's a no no it's just not it's an
unbelievable song yeah but it's not a
baseball it's a great
it's a song about everything what if is
baseball a part of the world
yeah then it's a song that song works
for everything
we already have a song it's the best
song
thank god i'm a country boy how does
that not work with baseball
it's not it's not a baseball song well
neither is take me out to the ball game
literally a baseball song listen to me
it's about a ball game
thank god i'm a country boy
on that's a song baby i'm not saying
it's not a
good song it's a great song it's not
about
baseball but it's about it's about heart
it's about a commitment to agriculture
no it's not basically it's a song
it's a song about pride
it's a song about having pride in
yourself
and the the fields that you're plowing
and the breakfast you'll be having
no it's about a guy who likes being from
the country hey daddy likes to have a
cake on the griddle
and he wants a cake on the [ __ ]
griddle
life ain't that much fun look i stand by
my decision back there
you have got to be out of your mind and
i think that was a good move
i wanted to finish out the season two i
wanted to see where this could go
but i'm afraid we went as far as take me
out to the ball game can get us
it was time for a changeup it was time
for what i always call a curveball
you're the first manager
in professional sports history to be
fired over a song
and i won't be the last because once no
i will not
because once people hear that song no
that is gonna be the seventh inning song
there's not a better song to stretch
to there's not a better take out to the
ball game oh we've heard it we get it
you're at the [ __ ] ball game what
more do you want you want to go to the
ball game again
or do you want to learn about the salt
of the earth people
who built this country on their [ __ ]
backs
anyway just go and pack up your locker
i'm open to other
songs too i just think take me out to
the ball game
sucks balls okay
okay i'm gonna miss the hell out of you
guys
we really could have gotten some stuff
done look coach you told me you taught
me how to just stick to absolutely
[ __ ]
insane you know the whole position stand
in your principles
if i can leave you guys i'm gonna make a
drink here but i'm to leave you guys
with if just stick to your principles
yes
yeah yeah okay i love you fellas
no tell me that song's not in your head
yeah it's in my head thank you the
yankees hired billy 12 days later
he's got to be like really yeah
this is the only job he ever wanted is
the manager uh he was introduced to the
game fans go [ __ ] crazy because billy
martin's back
billy cried casey stengel tries a lot
huh yeah he does cry a lot casey stengel
is at home he's battling leukemia
uh he watched on tv and he cries okay
yankees are bad sure but billy reshapes
them he gets rid of the slow guys
he brings in youth like the other i
didn't do that yeah keep these slow
pokes they're the key
um he brings in mickey rivers who was
very impulsive
and and ran up gambling debts he was
also known as mick the quick
because he's super fast and he gave his
stats another
really fast guy willie randolph so the
owner george steinbrenner
at this point has been when they hired
billy
he is suspended by major league baseball
george steinberg yes
because he gave illegal campaign
contributions to richard nixon and told
all his employees to lie about it
well if you're gonna put it on the line
for a politician make it a good one
that's the guy make it a winner so while
he was suspended
he started making speeches into a tape
recorder
and then the gm would bring it to the
clubhouse and put it on a stool
and play it for the players
strange super crazy
uh so after the fourth speech that billy
heard
when he came in he walked over and
kicked the stool over
and stopped the cassette and from that
day on
every time the cassette recorder was
player played a player would go kick it
over
okay okay
but then george is suspicious nobody's
telling steinbrenner they're like i went
over great george yeah
yeah so hit george's suspension is
lifted in march 76 so
now he can give his speeches in person
now we can kick the man himself over
and billy protests uh says you know
don't i can't have
no talking to my players and george
agrees george is like okay i won't i
won't give the speeches so instead they
agree that george will be allowed to
roam the field
while they're practicing and do as
little like how's your hand
well it billy found it very amusing
because he'd walk by
and say to a player quote okay pinella
now let's whip that bat around
right and and at the infielders he would
always yell step lively boys
yeah so just like what i would do yeah
and after come on catch that ball
get that going do good work athletically
after he would hurt him after he would
say that he would walk away and billy
would say
you're boys step lively and all the
players would laugh come on guys don't
forget to move
so george didn't know [ __ ] about
baseball sure
a player sprained an ankle and the team
trainer put ice on it
and george came over and said do
something don't you have colder ice
that's a fair question how cold was it
it's not cold enough not cold enough ice
yeah was it watery
yeah it was water leaking yeah that's
water yeah not cold enough
um but he spent money george spent money
the players had the best planes the best
buses
george steinbrenner is i don't know how
he had money he um
he started with like a factory and no he
wasn't real rich when he bought the
yankees
he bought them for 10 million dollars um
but he definitely made money you know
it it was just business issues um
and george georgia george would fight
too
they had a a team manager named billy
kane and
he and george and billy would argue over
travel arrangements all the time because
that's what billy cain did
and he and george got into a fist fight
in uh new orleans hotel lobby
or arguing over travel what was billy
like now that i've done
i really respect that you got to beat
the [ __ ] out of your travel guy in the
lobby sometimes
kane was fired and constantly rehired
sometimes he would get fired and then
just come in the next day like nothing
happened and it would totally be fine
that's a good situation billy and george
love each other but they would fight a
lot
but george let billy run the show
because he wanted to learn how to win
and billy had an amazing ability to see
everything on the field like i said
right so he was like this guy
is a you know he has a thing um
if someone came in on hard on one of
billy's players
like slid hard at him he would yell at
his team it was a [ __ ] play and the
veterans knew what to do he would like
fire them
and get these guys so everyone knew in
baseball if you hit the yankees the
yankees were gonna [ __ ] hit you a lot
harder right it was gonna be a lot worse
they kind of took on his personality
they would they started brawling the
first game in boston they got into a big
fight after a slide
um fans loved it right and they came and
celebrities came
and billy's famous again he's back in
new york he's back to the celebrity
he lives in a sheridan hotel in new
jersey however sure well i mean
back he's not back but he's blue back
ish he's backish he's back he's in the
city he's coaching
yeah he's in room 411 at the sheridan
new jersey but still
pretty back and across the street was a
dive bar called bottom of the barrel and
that's where
you'd usually find billy people would
call the bar to get a hold of him
oh god that's crazy it's also amazing
how like
dive bars will be like this is a sad
place and people are like that's where i
need to be
yes here's my here's my card your last
favor a table for one
um the yankees extend his contract three
years they go to the world series that
year did he get a home or is he still
no he's still in the sheraton he stays
in the sheraton for a long time
um they go to the world series they lose
to the reds okay now reggie jackson
yes he's a really big free agent he's
the biggest free agent out there
right a candy bar named after him like
he's a
really big what goes the candy bar the
reggie jackson candy brother reggie bar
you never heard of that yeah they had a
reggie bar um
he's a home run hitter he has been at
least
two locker room fist fights that i could
find with teammates
okay before notorious notoriously thin
skinned and just a dick
reggie jackson okay but george wants him
right because he's the biggest player
billy does not want him billy's like
this guy doesn't fit on the team
he wants a different player so
when they're trying to get reggie
billy's not invited to any of the
meetings
he's not invited when reggie signs he's
not invited to the press conference when
they announce reggie that's normal
and reggie does not contact billy after
he signs he didn't call the bar or
anything
and billy doesn't feel he doesn't call
reggie okay
and the press they say the right things
but billy knew reggie was
a square peg in a round hole the yankees
are like a blue collar team
and reggie is a big ego rich guy
attention hound
so george george steinbrenner is a
special kind of [ __ ]
okay if a reporter wanted a season
parking pass
george made them beg
if it was a young reporter he would have
him come into his office and he would
shoot rapid-fire questions at him
okay who's the greatest president should
truman have dropped the a-bomb on japan
who was america's best author what's
your favorite poem
okay and if you didn't like the answer
george would just scream names at him
and not give him a parking pass
okay so just super weird it's weird
like it's this is what rich guys do for
fun yeah
right sport right yeah it's sport to
them it's like they're bat it's like a
cat with a mouse like he
he has something that you have something
he needs have you ever heard jeff bezos
laugh
yeah it's pretty great it's pretty great
[Laughter]
i'm not real
i never i've never wanted a dick to blow
up more before oh no
yeah a week later the reporter would
come back and be grilled again so it was
a constant process so this guy could get
a parking pass right
because it's expensive he can't afford
it as a reporter eventually the guy
would get his parking pass
george never did this to win women
reporters okay
once a team intern
unknowingly parked his car in the wrong
spot and it caused
donald trump to have to wait to get his
car out oh my god
so george fired the teen right in front
of trump
jesus to make up for it
so that spring billy george and reggie
get along everything's going fine
season starts and then reggie tells
reporters his elbow hurts now billy
didn't like
i don't believe in injuries jackson
billy doesn't like people telling the
press what's up he's like that's [ __ ]
not what you tell
you telling i'm that's always i mean
that's always the case yeah you don't
reveal injury yeah
so he benches him and that leads to a
two and a half hour meeting
in the hotel with reggie and billy just
because he bench from that one game
and the next day reggie's brooding
around and reporters are like what's up
and reggie says quote i don't know
what's between us
so it's starting out good and then the
yankees start losing
okay and george wants billy to fix it or
he tells him he's gonna need a new job
fix this thing with reggie
so it's 11 games into the season okay
he's already
being threatened with being in the hot
seat okay so billy has reggie
pick the next game's lineup out of a hat
after after george threatened to fire
him so he's basically just saying
[ __ ] he's die yeah it's it's his version
of uh right
thank god i'm a country boy right right
right right
and they win that game okay okay that's
good that's
shitty if you're billy you're like uh
that shouldn't have worked
so then in an article reggie said he was
brought to
yankees uh because they lacked
leadership
so there's obviously guys on the side
shot across the bow quote
i'm this i'm the straw that stirs the
drink munson thinks he can be the straw
but he can only stir it bad thurman
munson is the catcher he's billy's
favorite he's the
leader and regis said he was misquoted
and then thurman monson said quote for
three thousand [ __ ] words
oh wow jesus so it's not going great no
i was misarticled
oh look at that there you go oh god
jeez the next game no one on the team
speaks to reggie
okay he hits a home run and the yankees
go over to greet him but then he goes to
the other dugout entrance to avoid his
teammates
reggie does yeah oh wow and then he sits
alone in the corner
the commentator beautiful home run and
reggie is avoiding his day he's going he
went into the other team's dugout so
that's kind of weird
we don't know where he is then he sits
alone in the corner and no one talks to
him so reporters ask him why he didn't
shake his
his teammate's hands and reggie says his
wrist was sore okay
sure right and then they asked them once
and then mudson said reggie was quote a
[ __ ] liar
okay so it's going well so that's why
you let george put the team together
that's right
two games later in detroit during the
first espn live
televised game or reggie so it's the
very first game reggie doesn't hustle
for
a ball and now he'd actually fought a
guy on his last team because he accused
the guy of not hustling and now he's not
hustling okay
and billy pulls reggie out of the game
and in the dugout they almost get into a
fight
on national television they're like
screaming at each other and and
it looks like they're gonna brawl a
coach has to pick up billy
he picks it like lift him up and pick
him up
to keep him from fighting reggie jackson
so he's lifted off the ground
like a little boy yeah that's very it's
like mini-me
reggie other other coaches pull reggie
into the clubhouse
as he's yelling quote you never liked me
this is all in front of a national
audience
you never liked me he's not the best
thing no it's not good you never liked
me
this is the first time anything like
this in sports has ever been televised
live okay no one's ever seen anything
like this
reggie now waits in the clubhouse and a
t-shirt
uh and cleats and he said his cleats
were on for good footing for the fist
fight that was going to happen oh
but two players talking about leaving
the stadium like dude you got to get the
[ __ ] out of here billy's crazy
and then afterwards billy says look i
handled the right way the yankee way
and reggie then invites all the
reporters to his hotel room
and he walks around talking drinking
wine
shirtless holding a bible okay
this is the blood right here um okay
it's i mean in some ways it feels like
he's
i wouldn't say met his match but it's
like
there is the publicity around something
like this makes it
i mean it's a little bit like you know
like the what's you know going on with
the packers and rogers right now like or
whenever you have a star like a star
athlete has a lot of power
yes you know a lot
uh so he in that when he's talking to
reporters he says he loves george and
he's being treated this way
because he's black but a lot of the
yankees are black so that's not really
right okay the guy's icing him are black
right okay
so george makes billy this is out of
town so george makes billy
reggie and the gm have breakfast and
billy says he didn't do anything wrong
and reggie so there's three guys at the
table and reggie talks to the gm oh he
does one of those
to tell billy what he says that's so
awkward it's like
it's also that can only go on for like
30 seconds before look i'm not gonna do
that this is what ellen does to people
right right like she did that to writers
right she would talk to a writer the
producer the writer would be a crossover
it's [ __ ] crazy this is what crazy
people do like this is
[Music]
when reggie said he hustled on the play
billy jumped up quote get up boy i'm
going to kick the [ __ ] out of you
and reggie says the gm you heard it he
called me boy
and then then you know they just
dissolved that they went their separate
ways right and then george flies in
and he's gonna fire billy okay but then
reggie put this tape recorder on the
stool
this is the one reggie's like you can't
fire billy because then everyone will
[ __ ] blame me
oh and reggie stops him from firing
billy
and weird little pickles right yeah he's
certainly put him i mean he's put
himself
he's caught between home and third yeah
so
so george orders billy to treat reggie
with respect
and then the other players are
constantly fighting with them everybody
[ __ ] hates him on the team and billy
just stays out of it he doesn't do
anything
it teams losing because of all this and
reggie says he's upset he's not hitting
fourth
and he keeps telling the press that and
finally the players are like dude just
[ __ ] bad and forth yeah so we'll shut
the [ __ ] up
and they he does and they start winning
again and they win the division so
reggie jackson's just a giant [ __ ]
baby right he's not playing well he's
sitting fifth and they
move him and he's then he starts playing
well right okay
um they go and they play the royals in
the playoffs the siri goes
it goes to the last game and then in the
last game
billy benches reggie because there's a
picture he's never faced before and he
doesn't want reggie to
you know go out there and try to hit
against him
and then is that weird
i think for the time it's not okay but
yeah it might be a little [ __ ] you
okay it sure sure could be um the
reggie's furious
they get into a a massive brawl during
the game because george brett
you know slides in hard and while
they're while there's a massive fight
they just catch billy just smiling like
he just loves it
like this is [ __ ] awesome yankees win
reggie comes in the game late and
heroics home run right and then
afterwards billy and reggie are your
best friends and they're celebrating
and billy praising reggie to the press
fans come to the airport to greet them
look at that
yeah there they are they're having a
great time together
but when they get to the airport billy's
the star right nobody wants to see
they chanting billy's name at the
airport they mob him
no other yankees getting that it's all
[ __ ] billy right
play the dodgers in the world series so
they go from
getting along great the third game
reggie is once again talking [ __ ]
okay he's second guess billy's pitching
choices he's angry
because billy said uh he's not going to
start him because
he wasn't going to start him because uh
the dodgers weren't pitching a lefty
that pisses reggie off and he says quote
i don't need to take that from nobody
especially him i know what i can do
and so they're just going back and forth
and billy's like math this is happening
in
the world today world series they have
another hotel meeting
okay so for hours and then afterwards
reggie's like it's all resolved we're
fine again
they win the next two games they're
hugging in the dugout
more like the hug out yeah uh yankees
extend billy's contract right then
reggie hits right then well you know not
right there but that
right in the middle of the world series
and then reggie hits three home runs on
three pitches in game six they win the
world series once again
reggie billy hugs champagne love
billy throws the victory party at the
sheridan well at home
yeah when they're back home and gretchen
realizes oh my god
i mean completely forgot like
i'm sure like she felt you know she's
like yeah i also exist in this story
well she realizes that he has two
mistresses there oh [ __ ]
two two messages at the who who
who's like what sort like
i don't know a drug one seems really
stressful yeah oh my god could you
at the same i mean i don't know if
you've ever had experience with the two
women you were dating in the same place
and how weird that is but now picture
your wife and two women you're dating
yeah
like you're like oh [ __ ] all right look
i gotta get rid of one of these
mistresses
so they start yelling at each other
billy and gretchen
in front of all the guests he throws his
drink on the ground and smashes
it and then he goes across the street to
uh bottom of the barrel
and drinks alone i sat there all by
myself i sat there and rested where no
one could bother me
by the way it's just it's where he's
supposed to be
at the bottom of the barrel that's right
i mean
his marriage is basically over right
it's uh
it's dave i'd like to say it's no guys
on base
two outs own two
not looking great right now for the
martin and gretchen marriage
so he's the toast of new york again
right they won the world series
and uh he's stringing with bill murray
and john belushi and aykroyd and
he's on talk shows and he's doing he's
taking commercial offers
light beer starts using athletes and ads
and billy was quote
the quasi manager of the light beer team
right
now he takes all these checks from
commercials and deposit them
but he doesn't pay income tax on them
that's fine
you can do that they're commercials
you're not supposed to
you don't tax those those does he did
you not know how it works no i didn't i
wouldn't oh yeah
that is non-taxable income because
because
i'm saying so so go ahead okay no it
just seemed like that's not a good
yeah what kind of accountant are you a
good one i save you a lot of money yeah
yeah
no for sure yeah yeah three years
i only work with clients for three years
that's sort of where i cut it off
his lawyer tried to get him how to to
understand how taxes work and he just
didn't he ignores it
yeah i was just it doesn't seem like he
didn't understand he was just like i
choose to not
he's troubled money he just gives out
like people always trying to stop him
from giving out so much money to people
like he's just
so at the beginning of the next season
reggie said he wouldn't get involved in
any drama this year he's like that's it
no drama but then they have a lot of
injuries and
they're not doing well and um george
starts putting them on commercial
flights to punish him oh jesus christ
so they're happy about that on one
flight after delay they're all [ __ ]
drunk and they're on this flight and
thurman munson
starts playing his music loud and a
passenger asks him to turn it down
quote mind your own mind your own
business [ __ ] face
and then and then there's yelling and
that
just makes me want to fly yeah billy
comes back and to calm things down but
it doesn't and then
yankees are fighting imagine the yankees
being in coach with you
that's really weird excuse me mr jeter i
gotta pee again
so it turns into chaos and and uh
they would never fly commercial again he
would always put him on private planes
but now george thinks billy's lost
control of the team
so george starts leaking to writers that
billy was going to be fired
okay smart and billy is like totally
drained and uh munson takes them out to
try to cheer him up but billy just
bursts into tears and is sobbing for
like 30 minutes
he said george doesn't know the team
they're yankees george isn't a yankee
and now munson starts leaking the papers
the reporters wrote the team wanted
george to get off billy's back
so it's like a war in the press right
and then at yankee stadium the fans give
billy a standing ovation so they're like
we're behind billy
okay hey reggie meets with george to
talk about all the shit's going on
they just end up arguing and now
george calls reggie boy okay jesus
so reggie tells him not to call me boy
george says get the [ __ ] out of my
office
reggie's like i'm not [ __ ] leaving
your office so george storms out of his
own office george leaves his office
then i quit my office
okay that's a
it's an admission of fear so during the
game that night
reggie signals for reggie billy signals
for reggie to bunt
okay now big home runners they don't
bunt right
he's extremely offended and
he bunts foul and then then he says go
ahead and swing away
right right billy's like swing but now
reggie's mad
right and he refuses to swing okay
that's a problem and he fouls out trying
to bunt
and now billy's [ __ ] furious the
game's on national tv
and reggie goes back to the dugout
expecting a fist fight like he's [ __ ]
storming in there ready to go
but billy just stays away from him and
then after the game he calls george in
the gm and they suspend reggie for five
games
wow and uh reggie is just
[ __ ] so billy sold out he didn't beat
the [ __ ] out yeah he's not for once
yeah he's a total coward
so reggie is just savaged by reporters
and his teammates
and they win without him they win four
straight games and he comes back in
chicago
and he tells the press he's done nothing
wrong and now the [ __ ] team's like
more livid everyone's more pissed i had
no idea about this side of reggie
jackson i mean i don't know much about
baseball
no yeah but people don't know how
incredible he was
that same night uh
billy's out drinking with his buddy bill
vek from another one of you yeah right
right right
and um bill vettel said hey is that
no he was chicago okay he was the minor
league
build the crazy stuff in chicago right
okay
and buildvex says hey i need to tell you
something
last month george tried to trade you to
cleveland
wow a manager he tried to trade his
manager well
but that that's so weird but that has
happened in the nba
and been floated in the nfl yeah like
um like doc rivers essentially like had
a
i i was like sort of traded to the
clippers from the cell like it's really
[ __ ] weird
really yeah i think i might be wrong i'm
sure i'll hear about it if i am but
that has happened a couple times but it
is the weirdest
yeah it's like it just i don't it just
like
it feels like management is not a part
of that they're like part of
the man yeah it's like yeah they're in
charge of the trades they're not part of
the trade right it's the craziest idea
yeah but also that's that this has got
to be the first time
probably yeah so billy's [ __ ] livid
and they leave that night
and they're going through the airport
and billy's been drinking
and as they go through the airport he
goes off on reggie to two reporters
okay quote here's what i'm saying shut
up reggie jackson
we don't need none of your [ __ ] we're
winning without you oh jesus
he said reggie and george deserved each
other because because one was a liar
and the other was convicted wow
now george had been convicted of making
the illegal
campaign contributions so reporters
called george and he asks them to
re-read this he's like what could you
say that again
and then he said send over a tape
recording i could put on a stool please
and they said quote i'm stunned i don't
know what to say
so the next day billy's lawyer's like
did you [ __ ] say this
and billy's like yeah billy said quote
no well
yes but not like it's come out but yes
like i was drunk do you know what i'm
saying
like listen to me that's exactly what
he's saying he's like
i mean i said it but i didn't want to
look i to be honest it comes down to
this
life where i'm from on the farm is kind
of laid back yeah
it's nothing like a country boy like
if you look at it it's kind of like it's
early to rise
early to sack you're from [ __ ]
berkeley thank god i'm a country boy no
want some wheat to chew on no billy time
so his lawyer says look you need to
retire
because if you get fired you won't get
paid but if you retire you will get paid
for health reasons
so he does okay
and he as he reads his resignation he's
quivering
and almost crying and his old teammate
phil rizzuto said quote i was worried he
was going to throw himself off the
balcony or something
well that's how you go out now back in
new york
george gets tons of death threats okay
fans threaten to never go to another
yankee game right
they start burning tickets outside the
stadium that's not
great the media is attacking billy
and attacking george pro billy okay
reggie is blamed for starting it all wow
and then we'll do part two what i'm
trying to fill
wow okay yeah
all right we'll be back right after
these
words
right after this is this one is the is
this one
you